unfortunately getting the rights to both
Freddy and Jason was hard enough but
wrangling Evil Dead on top of it proved
nearly impossible the idea actually
stems from an Easter egg and Jason Goes
to Hell where a copy of the necro
namicon from Evil Dead is implied to be
responsible for Jason's power according
to a Sci-Fi interview with that film's
director Adam Marcus he was quote
setting up a mythology that Jason's mom
wanted to sum back so badly that she
reads from the Necronomicon and brings
about the resurrection of her son as a
result the notion to cross all three
franchises together seemed like a
natural fit Bruce Campbell meanwhile
wasn't all that excited about the
concept and eventually he walked away he
said on Reddit I'm not real interested
in crossovers one of the main reasons
why Ash versus Jason versus Freddy did
not come to pass is because we couldn't
control any other character other than
Ash that felt like a creatively bankrupt
way to go